مرحبًا دونالد جون
ترامب أقسم رسميًا أن رئاسة دونالد ترامب
ستبدأ
بكذبة استيقظت هذا الصباح وأقوم بتشغيل
إحدى الشبكات
وأظهروا حقلاً فارغًا قلت انتظر ، لقد
ألقيت خطابًا بحثت عن الحقل هل بدا وكأنه
مليون ونصف شخص
كان هذا أكبر جمهور
شهد على الإطلاق فترة تنصيب ،
أعتقد أنه في عقله
لا يستطيع التمييز بين
ما كان صحيحًا وما هو خطأ
، ولا أعتقد أنه كان
مهمًا لهم بشكل خاص.  كان بولتون
مستشار الأمن القومي لترامب ،
إذا كان بإمكانه إقناع الناس بأن ما
يريده أن يكون صحيحًا ،
فإنه سيحاول فعل ذلك والأسابيع التي
سبقت توليه منصبه ، سيطلق دونالد ترامب
العبارة التي
كان سيستخدمها للتخلص من
أي
شيء تقريبًا.  أخبار كاذبة بهاتين الكلمتين
قال دونالد ترامب لمؤيديه
إنهم لم يعودوا بحاجة ولا يمكنهم الوثوق
بالمؤسسات ، والحسابات الرسمية ، والمنافذ الإخبارية
التي كرست نفسها لتقديم
حقيقة فعلية.  من الآن فصاعدًا ، كان ترامب هو
الذي سيقول لهم ما يجب تصديقه
قبل أيام قليلة ، لقد أطلقت على الأخبار الزائفة
عدو الشعب
وهم أعداء الناس
[تصفيق]
كان يكذب بشأن أي شيء ويتذكر فقط
ما  ما تراه وما تقرأه
ليس ما يحدث ، كان بإمكانه إخبار
الناس أن العشب أزرق في الواقع
والسماء حمراء
وأنه كان سيصدقه بعض
أتباعه أن هناك
ظاهرة شبيهة بالعبادة
كما هي  يتعلق بترامب على شخص ما أن
يفعل ذلك ،
أنا الشخص المختار ، وقد يبدو هذا
غريبًا للغاية بالنسبة لكثير من
مشاهديك ، لكني أشعر وكأنه قد
مسحه الله ،
فأنا فعلاً دونالد ترامب ، نعم أشعر
وكأن الله قد انضم إليه ،
نعم أفعل ذلك  أشعر وكأنه يحمل
مسحة الله هناك
لأنه فاز طوال الوقت
فهو قائد لا يصدق وعندما
يتحدث يضرب
على وتر حساس فينا يمسك
بنا ونذهب نعم هذه هي الحقيقة
ليست صحيحة كل شيء
ولكن معظم كل ما يقوله يمسك  لنا بعد
التمديد  لقد رأت في ورقة رابحة فرصة نادرة
لمواصلة دفع
جدول أعمال بديل يمين ونعم من خلال الطريقة
التي يحاولون بها
سلب تاريخنا وتراثنا ، تراهم ستيف بانون الذي كان قد سلم رسائل ترامب يدويًا
أصبح الآن مخفيًا في البيت الأبيض
تحويل نظرته إلى العالم
إلى سياسة ، لم يحن الوقت
لتوحيد البلاد ، لقد حان الوقت لمواجهة
النخب في هذا البلد ،
خذ الشعلة إليه ، وضربه بشعلة
[موسيقى]
سيكون
الأمر التنفيذي
مع بانون إلى جانبه  كان يوقع
سلسلة من الأوامر
يُطلق عليها أحدهم اسم حظر السفر للمسلمين ،
والبعض الآخر
يقيد الهجرة ببناء
الجدار ويزيد من أمن الحدود ،
وكل ذلك بناءً على كذبة مفادها أن
الغزو الجماعي للمجرمين الخطرين كان
جارياً.
من المخدرات
والمجرمين والأشخاص
الذين ليس لدينا أي فكرة عنهم
[الموسيقى]
كان أتباع الرابحة
يغذون نظريات المؤامرة من قبل الرئيس
على الراديو التليفزيوني وعلى الإنترنت
قوافل المهاجرين ، نعم ، أعتقد تمامًا
أنها نظمت من كل قلبي ،
أعني أن هناك الكثير من الأدلة على
وجود أعمال شغب ، حيث أن آشلي بابيت
قد تنشر مقاطع فيديو صاخبة حول المشاكل على
الحدود الجنوبية التي
أعيش فيها على بعد حوالي 15 دقيقة من حدود تيخوانا
وهكذا  هذا شيء أعتبره
شخصيًا حقًا لأنني أستطيع رؤية
التأثيرات
التي ما زالوا يحاولون رسمها في
قافلة المهاجرين هذه ، فهي مليئة بالنساء
والأطفال لأن هذا هو ما تدفعه وسائل الإعلام
ولكن دعني أخبرك الآن
أن الحدود هي عرض هراء مطلق.
نعتقد أن دونالد ترامب هو
الرئيس الوحيد الذي شغلناه في المنصب والذي كان في
الواقع
يتحدث
علانية لتمثيلنا الأمريكيين المنسيين خجول غريفين
الذي سيبدأ رعاة البقر من أجل ترامب
سيخاطر بمستقبله
على الرئيس أي شخص يعيش على
الحدود الجنوبية  يعرف
أنه أمر خطير للغاية مثل
ادعائه بشأن الأخبار المزيفة التي قد تستخدم
قوة الخوف
مرارًا وتكرارًا لتحفيز قاعدته.
فكر في نفسه كرئيس للولايات المتحدة ، وكان يعتبر
نفسه رئيسًا
لقاعدته السياسية ، فقد شدد على
إحساسهم بالاستياء ،
ومرارة الخسارة ،
وشمل جزء من قاعدته السياسية
المتعصبين للبيض
الذي رأى هؤلاء الأشخاص على أنهم مؤيدون رابحة
وكان
يفتقر فقط إلى  القدرة أو الرغبة في
النظر في الآثار الأوسع